i've been getting more and more emails
from from you guys from people in the
audience where
folks are increasingly confused about
is russia making progress is russia
going to be taking over ukraine
or is russia losing because anecdotally
we have for example what we're going to
start with today the story of russia
seizing the first major ukrainian city
which would suggest well yeah it does
seem as though russia is ultimately
going to take ukraine but at the same
time there are widespread reports of
russian soldiers breaking down crying
surrendering in ukraine calling mommy
quite literally i mean soldiers just
calling their moms uh and how could both
be true and the the way that both can be
true
is that on the one hand
russia's military is so dramatically
larger and more powerful than that of
ukraine
that there's some feeling of almost
inevitability as to the ability of
russia to make progress into ukraine but
at the same time individually there are
soldiers
groups of soldiers that don't want to be
there that don't want to do what they've
been sent to do and are just bailing and
both can be true because the conflict is
becoming so widespread and more than one
thing can happen at the same time so
bear that in mind as we talk about this
first headline
the bbc reporting russian troops have
taken control of the key city of
keresun
and this is considered the first quote
major city taken control of by russia
close to 300 000 people so not a massive
metropolis but certainly not a small
town bbc reporting russian forces have
seized control of a key port city in
southern ukraine
kerason is the first major city taken by
russia after heavy fighting now one week
into the invasion its mayor igor kolikav
kolikayev
said russian troops forced their way
into the city council building and have
now imposed a curfew on residents so
the the city appears to truly have been
taken in the literal sense of the word
several cities are under intense
shelling wednesday was one of the most
destructive days of the fighting an
investigation into possible war crimes
and crimes against humanity has been
launched in the icc we talked about that
request earlier this week russia has for
the first time admitted taking heavy
military casualties
498 troops killed 1600 injured now this
this number is not a small detail
um for
a force as overwhelming as that of of
russia's is relative to ukraine's the
fact that in a weak
500 they're admitting 500 have died and
remember what they admit and the full
scope of it may be two different things
they're admitting to almost 100 dead a
day now does putin care about that no
probably not but that is not an
insignificant number based on the
military analyses that i've seen now one
other thing i want to point to here that
is uh important
in a facebook post mr kolikov who's the
mayor of curson said russian forces were
in control of the city
he urged russian soldiers not to shoot
at civilians
saying there are no ukrainian forces in
the city and increasingly and as i've
said to you guys before
we are tr when things are moving so
quickly it can be difficult to know
what's true and what's not true
there are now
regularly claims of russian aggression
against just random civilians
in multiple instances and here the mayor
is coming out and saying there just
there are no soldiers here anybody you
see is a civilian please don't shoot
anybody now the counter that russia has
already started is well there have been
numerous calls for a week now for any
able-bodied individual
to take up arms and so the fact that
they are civilians doesn't mean they are
unarmed or that they don't present a
threat to russian troops that's the
counter
but the mayor of croissant saying
there's no troops here
please don't shoot civilians and the
belief is that indeed uh uh civilians
have been killed that as we told you
earlier this week a kindergarten was
bombed an orphanage was bombed etc
that's the the latest um there there is
this you know when we imagine the sort
of prototypical
uh
police state kind of military rule some
of these elements are in place um
the uh conditions set by russian forces
include a curfew from 8 pm to 6 a.m
only going out in groups of two
and allowing only cars carrying food
medicine and supplies to enter the city
driving slowly so this is quickly
quickly taking the
uh
ambiance and that that term does not
seem strong enough but the ambiance of a
military police state and tomorrow on
the program you know for those saying
how long could this go on could this be
over in five days could this be months
the the answers are both yes but there
are now reports from u.s and america u.s
and british intelligence
uh and foreign foreign ministries that
this could be a 10 to 20 year conflict
now that doesn't mean it would be like
this for 20 years
but that it could be one of these
protracted uh conflicts and we'll talk
about that on tomorrow's program